ALL RIGHT. SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER AFTER EIGHT YEARS AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE. GEO. THIS
WILL BE MY LAST INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON COMPACTS. SO ENJOY
THESE WORDS FOR ONE LAST TIME.
I'M SENATOR BILL DODD, CHAIRMAN
OF THE GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS
COMMITTEE. TODAY WE WILL BE
HOLDING THREE INFORMATION
HEARINGS. TWO ARE SIMPLE ONE
YEAR COMPACT EXTENSIONS FOR THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA AND THE
TRINIDAD RANCHERIA. WE WILL
FOLLOW THOSE HEARINGS WITH THE
TABLE MOUNTAIN COMPACT HEARING.
FOR THOSE OF YOU UNFAMILIAR WITH
THE SENATE'S PROCEDURE, THE
ESTABLISHED POLICY ALLOWS FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
DETAILS OF THE COMPACT TO BE
FOLLOWED BY A VOTE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN
HERE TODAY. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
BILL RATIFYING THE TWO COMPACT
EXTENSIONS WILL BE SB 931 BY
YOURS TRULY, SB 931 WILL BE
TAKEN UP BY THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
NEXT WEEK. ONCE THAT BILL COMES
TO THE SENATE, THE BILL WILL BE
REFERRED STRAIGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR A VOTE OF THE FULL
SENATE BODY. WITH THAT, LET US
BEGIN OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE PICAYUNE EXTENSION. HERE
TO TESTIFY IS MATTHEW LEE,
SENIOR ADVISOR FOR TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. MR. LEE, WELCOME AND
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN.
HONORABLE MEMBERS, IT'S A
PLEASURE AND AN HONOR TO BE HERE
THIS MORNING, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
LAST INFORMATIONAL HEARING BY A
GREAT CHAIR. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT OPPORTUNITY. I'M HAPPY TO
START WITH WHAT I HOPE IS AN
EASY ONE TODAY. THIS IS FOR THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA OF CHUKCHANSI
INDIANS DOWN IN COARSEGOLD,
NORTH OF FRESNO, NEAR YOSEMITE.
LARGE EXISTING GAMING OPERATION.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO PRESERVE THE
STATUS QUO OF THAT EXISTING
GAMING OPERATION, INCLUDING, I
BELIEVE, MORE THAN 700 UNION
JOBS. WHILE THE PROCESS
CONTEMPLATED BY THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT CAN
CONTINUE TO PLAY OUT, WE DON'T
HAVE A NEW COMPACT TO REPLACE
THE EXPIRING COMPACT AT THIS
TIME. WE COULD STILL GET ONE,
AND SO WANT TO PRESERVE THE
STATUS QUO SO THAT THAT EXISTING
GAMING OPERATION CAN, CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. WHILE THAT
PROCESS PLAYS OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR. LEE, ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL MOVE TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE ROOM. MR.
QUINTANA. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, SIR DAVID
QUINTANA, ON BEHALF OF THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA OF CHUKCHANSI
INDIANS, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND MATT
LEE FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH US.
AND YOU, CHAIRMAN DODD, FOR
ALLOWING US TO BE AN SB 931 FOR
OUR EXTENSION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELL, THAT CONCLUDES OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
PICAYUNE COMPACT EXTENSION.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE TRINIDAD
RANCHERIA COMPACT EXTENSION. MR.
LEE, FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A VERY SIMILAR SITUATION
HERE. THIS IS FOR A SMALL
EXISTING GAMING OPERATION UP IN
TRINIDAD ON THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
COAST. SIMILAR SITUATION.
COMPACT. SO THERE ARE ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS TO REPLACE THE
EXPIRING 1999 COMPACT. REMAIN
OPTIMISTIC THAT THOSE COULD
STILL PRODUCE A NEW COMPACT. BUT
WE DON'T HAVE IT YET AND REALIZE
THAT THE EXISTING COMPACT
EXPIRES AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO TO PRESERVE THE STATUS QUO AS
TO THAT EXISTING GAMING
OPERATION, ARE ASKING FOR AA1
YEAR EXTENSION AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS? I DO
HAVE A QUESTION. SO ON THESE
COMPACTS, WHAT'S THE NORMAL TIME
FRAME FOR THEM TO BE ENACTED?
ARE THEY THREE YEAR FIVE YEAR,
TEN YEAR. BECAUSE WE'RE DOING
ONE YEAR ONES RIGHT NOW FOR
THESE PARTICULAR THREE. AND I'M
CURIOUS WHAT IS SO DIFFICULT
ABOUT THESE NEGOTIATIONS VERSUS
THE OTHER ONES. SO THE BASIC
TIMELINE HERE IS THAT THERE ARE
A LARGE NUMBER OF COMPACTS FROM
1999 AND SOME FROM 2000, THAT
WERE ENTERED INTO RIGHT WHEN THE
STATE FIRST LEGALIZED TRIBAL
GAMING. THOSE COMPACTS TENDED TO
BE FOR 20 TO 25 YEARS. SO
THERE'S BEEN THIS WAVE OF, 99
COMPACTS THAT HAVE BEEN EXPIRING
IN RECENT YEARS. ALMOST ALL OF
THOSE HAVE NOW BEEN REPLACED IN
SOME FASHION, MOST OFTEN BECAUSE
THE STATE HAS BARGAINED FOR A
NEW LONG TERM COMPACT. AND THE
TERM OF THOSE COMPACTS IS ITSELF
A SUBJECT OF NEGOTIATION. WHEN
WE'RE BARGAINING FOR THE
COMPACT. BUT 2025 YEARS TENDS TO
BE THE RIGHT BALLPARK, YOU COULD
SEE LONGER, YOU COULD SEE
SHORTER, BUT THAT'S SORT OF THE
ORDINARY COURSE. THESE ONE YEAR
EXTENSIONS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE TODAY, ARE BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE, PENDING
NEGOTIATIONS THAT WE STILL HAVE
LEFT. WE HAVE NOT YET BEEN ABLE
TO REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THOSE
OR TO OTHERWISE RESOLVE THOSE, I
DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
CONFIDENTIAL SUBSTANCE OF, HOW
THE NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING OR
WHAT'S BEING BARGAINED FOR, BUT
BUT IT IS TRUE THAT THESE ARE
TAKING LONGER THAN ALL THE
OTHERS. I REMAIN OPTIMISTIC THAT
BY THIS TIME NEXT YEAR, WE'LL BE
COMING BACK TO YOU WITH A LONG
TERM 2025, 30 YEAR COMPACT.
RIGHT. WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT,
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONFIDENTIALITY IN
WHAT YOU'RE BARGAINING FOR, BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME OF
THOSE THINGS ARE AND, AND WHY
THESE COMPACTS ARE ANY
DIFFERENT. THEY'RE ALMOST
BOILERPLATE WITH OTHER COMPACTS
AND WHY THESE, THESE THREE ARE
SINGLED OUT IS KIND OF BEYOND ME
AS FAR AS WHY, YOU KNOW, WE NEED
MORE NEGOTIATING LEVERAGE WITH
THEM, I DON'T THINK SO. I THINK
THEY NEED TO BE TREATED JUST
LIKE THE OTHER ONES. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, I'M HOPING THAT AS YOU AS
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE,
THAT WE STAY IN OUR LANE AS FAR
AS OUR GOVERNMENT VERSUS THEIR
SOVEREIGNTY AND, AND, AND
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH FOR THE
SAME THINGS THAT THE OTHER
COMPACTS HAVE. SO THAT'S MY
COMMENT ABOUT THESE TWO. AND
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT THE THIRD ONE
IN A MINUTE. YES, SIR. HEAR THAT?
LOUD AND CLEAR. AND THAT'S 100%
CONSISTENT WITH OUR POSITION AND
OUR PRACTICE. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. LEE. SO, I WANT
TO NOW MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
TRINIDAD COMPACT EXTENSION IN
THE ROOM HERE. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NONE. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR INFO HEARING ON
THE TRINIDAD COMPACT EXTENSION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE TABLE
MOUNTAIN COMPACT. MR. LEE,
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN, MR. CHAIRMAN.
HONORABLE MEMBERS,
REPRESENTATIVES OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS, MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE. THIS COMPACT IS FOR THE
TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA, THIS
UNLIKE THE OTHER TWO. THIS IS A
FULL, A FULL, LONG TERM COMPACT,
IT WOULD BE FOR UP TO 3000
GAMING DEVICES AT UP TO THREE
FACILITIES. ALTHOUGH ONE OF
THOSE FACILITIES WOULD BE VERY
SMALL. NO MORE THAN 50 DEVICES.
THE TERMS IN THE COMPACT
RELATING TO THE STATE'S
REGULATORY COSTS ARE PRETTY
STANDARD. THERE'S A FUND CALLED
THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND
THAT COVERS THE STATE'S
REGULATORY COSTS AND THERE'S A
FORMULA FOR DETERMINING A
TRIBE'S CONTRIBUTIONS TO THAT
FUND UNDER THE COMPACT THAT'S
HERE. THERE IS A SEPARATE FUND
CALLED THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND, WHICH IS A MECHANISM THAT
THE STATE ADMINISTERS, BUT DOES
NOT DIRECTLY RECEIVE MONEY FROM,
THAT IS A TRUST FUND
ADMINISTERED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
LIMITED GAMING AND NON-GAMING
TRIBES. THERE'S A SLIDING SCALE
OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO THAT REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF DEVICES THAT HERE
THERE IS, A FUND TO MITIGATE
IMPACTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM THE GAMING FACILITY, HAPPY
TO SAY MORE ABOUT THAT, BUT
THAT'S THAT'S HERE TOO, THERE
ARE SOME OF THE, YOU KNOW, VERY
STANDARD, TYPICAL INSURANCE
TERMS THAT WE LIKE TO SEE IN
THESE COMPACTS TO ENSURE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
WORKERS ARE, PROTECTED AND CAN
SEEK FINANCIAL COMPENSATION FOR
HARMS THAT MIGHT BEFALL THEM.
THOSE ARE HERE. THERE ARE ALSO
ADDITIONAL WORKER PROTECTIONS IN
THIS COMPACT, VERY SIMILAR TO
THE WORKER PROTECTIONS THAT WE
ALWAYS BARGAINED FOR IN ALL OF
OUR COMPACTS, VERY SIMILAR TO
THE WORKER PROTECTIONS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN IN ALL OF OUR RECENT
COMPACTS. THOSE INCLUDE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE, STATE LAW
PROTECTIONS IN TERMS OF
DISCRIMINATION, RETALIATION,
THINGS LIKE THAT, IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT CLASSIFICATIONS,
WORKERS COMP. IT ALSO INCLUDES
WHAT'S CALLED A TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE, THE TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE. HERE
IS EXTREMELY SIMILAR, VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE THAT WE
INCLUDE IN ALL OF OUR COMPACTS.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT
ESTABLISHES ESTABLISHES A
TRANSPARENT AND FAIR AND LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD OR FRAMEWORK.
RELATED TO, THE, POTENTIAL
FORMATION OF A LABOR UNION
WITHIN THE GAMING FACILITY. THE
POTENTIAL ORGANIZATION AND
REPRESENTATION OF WORKERS AT
THAT AT THAT FACILITY BY A LABOR
UNION. SO THAT'S HERE TOO. IT
MATCHES THE WORKER PROTECTIONS
IN ALL OF OUR COMPACTS THAT WE
ALWAYS BARGAINED FOR. HAPPY TO
SAY MORE ABOUT THAT IF IT'S
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? IT'S GOING TO BE
HELPFUL, SO LAST WEEK THEY WERE
WE HAD A SERIES OF COMPACTS THAT
WE WENT THROUGH LAST WEEK, AND
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ONE OF
THEM. AND THEN IT GOT PULLED TO
THE LAST MINUTE. WHAT KIND OF
NEGOTIATIONS OR WHAT KIND OF NEW
PROVISIONS WERE AGREED TO IN
THIS LAST WEEK THAT THAT
PREVENTED THEM FROM HAVING THEIR
THEIR HEARING LAST WEEK? I AM
NOT AWARE OF ANY NEW
NEGOTIATIONS OR NEW AGREEMENTS
IN THE PAST WEEK, AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE NOT PARTICIPATED
IN THOSE. ALL RIGHT. SO
ESSENTIALLY, A LOT OF THIS WAS
ABOUT THE LABOR AND UNION.
CORRECT? I COULDN'T SPEAK TO WHY
THIS COMMITTEE CHOOSES TO
SCHEDULE CERTAIN THINGS FOR
HEARING AND WHY IT DOESN'T. NOW
OKAY. SO MY COMMENT ON THIS IS,
IS GOING TO BE, THOSE TYPE OF
NEGOTIATIONS ARE NOT THEY'RE A
SOVEREIGN NATION. IT'D BE LIKE
US GOING TO SAUDI ARABIA AND
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO WITH
THEIR LABOR. AND WE SHOULDN'T BE
DOING THAT. I THINK IT'S WRONG.
AND WE CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T BE,
YOU KNOW, TRYING TO DELAY AND
CAUSE ANXIETY BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
YOU HAVE AN EXPIRING CONTRACT AT
THE END OR COMPACT AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR. AND IT IS NOT FAIR
FOR PEOPLE TO BE LEVERAGED THAT
WAY. AND SO ANYWAY, I HOPE IN
THE FUTURE THAT WE AGREE AS, AS
YOU KNOW, OUR GOVERNMENT STAYS
IN OUR LANE WHEN DEALING WITH
OUR INDIAN, OUR OUR TRIBAL
NATIONS, WHEN WE'RE DOING THESE
COMPACTS AND MINIMIZE THAT KIND
OF LEVERAGING, WHICH IS, IS
CAUSING DELAYS SO THAT WE CAN,
YOU KNOW, TRY AND GET A BETTER
DEAL FOR LABOR. SIR, I JUST WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR, FOR THE
RECORD, BECAUSE I THINK YOU'VE
HIT ON AN IMPORTANT POINT AND I,
IN TERMS OF SUBSTANCE, I, I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY. NOTHING ABOUT. THE
TIMING OF THIS HEARING HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH ME OR OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE STATE'S
NEGOTIATING TEAM SEEKING TO
REOPEN NEGOTIATIONS OR OTHERWISE
SEEK FURTHER CONCESSIONS. I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR. FOR THE
RECORD, I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
GUYS DID NOT HAVE ANYTHING. THIS
WAS NOT PULLED BY BY YOU GUYS.
THIS WAS PULLED BY US GUYS AND
NOT US. BUT, YOU KNOW, MEMBERS
OF OUR BODY, THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY. AND THAT I WANT TO SEND A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING. AND WE
OWE PEOPLE AN APOLOGY FOR EVEN
TRYING IT. OKAY, MR. LEE, I DO
HAVE A QUESTION. ANYBODY ELSE?
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, AND I
WANT TO JUST THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE. I KNOW THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND, YOU KNOW,
I THINK IF I MAY ADD A LITTLE
BIT TO WHAT YOU WERE SAYING,
SIR, YOU KNOW, I'VE HEARD
CONCERNS ABOUT, CONTRACTS
EXPIRING AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
AS WELL, AND SOME CONCERNS. AND
SO IS THERE ANYTHING YOU COULD
ADD TO THAT THAT, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, CLEARLY THESE
CONTRACTS NEED TO BE TAKEN CARE
OF AND THEY NEED TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE. BUT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN SHARE
IN TERMS OF CONCERNS AROUND,
CONTRACTS EXPIRING AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. SO, IN TERMS OF
COMPACTS EXPIRING AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR WITH THE THREE ITEMS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TODAY, I
BELIEVE WILL BE IN VERY GOOD
SHAPE. THESE ARE THE LAST, SO
THERE ARE, SOME COMPACTS WHERE
THERE IS AN EXPIRING COMPACT,
BUT WE HOPE TO HAVE A NEW LONG
TERM COMPACT IN PLACE, RATIFIED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND APPROVED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
INTERIOR SO THAT IT CAN TAKE
EFFECT BY JANUARY 1ST OF NEXT
YEAR. THAT'S THAT'S ONE CATEGORY
OF COMPACT. AND THAT TAKES CARE
OF, MANY, I BELIEVE, 3 OR 4 OF
THE COMPACTS THAT WE HAVE LEFT
IN OUR WHOLE, UNIVERSE OF
POTENTIAL COMPACTS. THEN THERE
IS A SMALLER UNIVERSE, WHICH ARE
THESE SHORT TERM EXTENSIONS
WHERE THERE IS SOME PROSPECT OF
FUTURE NEGOTIATION WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE TO REACH A LONG TERM
COMPACT IN THOSE, AND WE ARE
WHERE THERE IS STILL A PROSPECT
OF FURTHER NEGOTIATION, WE ARE
SEEING THESE ONE YEAR EXTENSIONS
PRECISELY FOR THE REASON YOU
IDENTIFIED, SO THAT THE STATUS
QUO ISN'T DISRUPTED COME JANUARY
1ST. THEN THERE IS ANOTHER
CATEGORY OF COMPACTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO SAY MORE ABOUT THIS
PROCESS, BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
USEFUL INFORMATION TO, TO HAVE
ACROSS THE BOARD, THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO REACH A DEAL. THERE
HAS BEEN LITIGATION THAT
LITIGATION IS ALMOST OVER. THERE
IS REALLY NOTHING FURTHER FOR
THE STATE TO DO. AND WHAT IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN, WHAT IS WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN OR QUITE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN IS THAT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF THE INTERIOR IS
GOING TO ISSUE WHAT ARE CALLED
SECRETARIAL PROCEDURES, WHERE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REGULATES
A GAMING OPERATION DIRECTLY,
WITHOUT ANY SIGNIFICANT ROLE FOR
THE STATE. OBVIOUSLY, WE WANT
THAT PROCESS TO PLAY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND WILL DO
OUR PART TO KEEP IT MOVING. SO
MY HOPE AND EXPECTATION IS THAT
TO THE EXTENT, YOU KNOW, TO THE
EXTENT IT'S UP TO US, CERTAINLY
TO THE EXTENT THERE IS THE
PROSPECT OF FURTHER, YOU KNOW,
FURTHER NEGOTIATIONS THAT COULD
PRODUCE A COMPACT. THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE SEEING THESE ITEMS COME
BEFORE YOU IN HEARINGS LIKE THIS
ONE, PRECISELY SO THAT WE DON'T
DISRUPT DISRUPT EXISTING GAMING
OPERATIONS. ON CHEN ONE. SO I
JUST WANT TO DISCUSS ONE MORE
TOPIC. YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL,
I'M A UNION MEMBER AS A TEACHER,
OF COURSE. AND I KNOW I WASN'T
AWARE THAT, YOU KNOW, FIRST OF
ALL, I KNOW THAT WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
GIVE, YOU KNOW, ALL OUR UNIONS,
THE BEST POSSIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE POWER TO NEGOTIATE AND
BARGAIN AND, YOU KNOW, GET THE
BEST DEAL THAT THEY CAN GET FOR
THEMSELVES. BUT IS IT STANDARD
TO CHOOSE A UNION FOR THEM? WE
ABSOLUTELY DON'T CHOOSE A UNION
FOR ANYONE. AND SO I THINK THE
SHORT ANSWER IS NO. THE TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE I
MENTIONED IS ABOUT CREATING A
LEGAL FRAMEWORK THAT COULD
FACILITATE ACCESS TO A UNION. IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANYONE CHOOSE TO BE
UNIONIZED, AND IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T CHOOSE A SPECIFIC UNION.
OKAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD. I JUST
I'LL BE BRIEF. I WANTED TO
AFFIRM, YOU KNOW, THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN RAISED BY
SENATOR TO SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATOR GROVE HAS SPOKEN VERY
ELOQUENTLY AND PASSIONATELY
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AND, YOU KNOW,
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IS, YOU
KNOW, THE TRIBES ARE EITHER
SOVEREIGN OR THEY'RE NOT. AND I
THINK WHAT I WANT THE TRIBES TO
HEAR FROM THIS MORNING IS THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS BODY
THAT DO BELIEVE THEY ARE
SOVEREIGN, AND THEY DO. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO NEGOTIATE THEIR COMPACTS IN
IN GOOD FAITH. AND SOME OF US
THINK THAT THAT GOOD FAITH IS
ADULTERATED A LITTLE BIT IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS. AND, I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT, BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN VERY
ELOQUENTLY ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
ANYBODY ELSE? OKAY THANK YOU,
MR. LEE. NOBODY ELSE. OKAY.
WHERE AM I? HERE WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO CHAIRWOMAN MICHELLE HEREDIA
CORDOVA, WHO IS HERE IN THE
ROOM. CHAIRWOMAN, GOOD MORNING,
AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
ALL RIGHT. HELLO, HELLO, HEALY.
HEALY. GREETINGS. I AM MICHELLE
HEREDIA CORDOVA, AND I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING THE TRIBAL
CHAIRWOMAN FOR TABLE MOUNTAIN
RANCHERIA. SOVEREIGN BAN OF MONO
PEOPLE. AND THE WORDS I SHARE
TODAY, I SHARE IN A GOOD WAY.
OVER THE PAST TWO WEEKS, MY
FELLOW COUNCIL MEMBERS AND I
HAVE WALKED THE HALLS ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND HAVING OUR
COMPACT HEARD. AND DURING THAT
TIME SOMEONE REMARKED THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE
STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF THOSE
WHO COME BEFORE US. AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT SENTIMENT IS NOT
LOST ON US, FOR NOT ONLY DO WE
STAND ON THEIR SHOULDERS, BUT WE
CARRY THEIR BLOOD, THEIR SWEAT
AND THEIR TEARS FROM THE
GENOCIDE, SLAVERY AND
DISPLACEMENT TO FORCED
ASSIMILATION. THERE CAN BE NO
COMPENSATION GREAT ENOUGH TO
MAKE REPARATIONS FOR WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE HAVE
ENDURED. THIS COMPACT IS NOT
JUST AN AGREEMENT OR A CONTRACT,
FOR WE ARE NOT A BUSINESS OR A
CORPORATION FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
THE BOTTOM LINE. FOR US, GAMING
REVENUE HAS BEEN A LIFELINE,
HELPING US PIECE TOGETHER WHAT
WAS BROKEN. WITH THIS REVENUE,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
BEST MEDICAL CARE FOR OUR TRIBAL
CITIZENS, AS WELL AS FOR OUR
1300 PLUS EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON BUILDING A NEW
MEDICAL FACILITY TO EXPAND OUR
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC, ALONG
WITH OUR OWN MEDICAL OPERATION.
WE HAVE MADE MAJOR CONTRIBUTIONS
AND OUR LONG TIME PARTNERS WITH
COMMUNITY MEDICAL CENTERS, SAINT
AGNES AND VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. IN TERMS OF HOUSING,
WE CAN NOW AFFORD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS POWER,
WATER AND ROADS NEEDED TO BUILD
HOMES AND BRING OUR TRIBAL
CITIZENS BACK TO THEIR ANCESTRAL
LANDS FOR EDUCATION, WE COVER
FULL TUITION FOR OUR TRIBAL
CITIZENS SO THEY CAN PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND RETURN WITH
THAT KNOWLEDGE TO HELP
STRENGTHEN OUR TRIBE. WE ALSO
HAVE A PRESCHOOL THAT SERVES
BOTH OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITY AND
THE FAMILIES OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
WE CONTRIBUTE TO OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS THROUGH DONATIONS AND
SPONSORSHIPS, AND HAVE A LONG
STANDING PARTNERSHIP WITH FRESNO
STATE IN CULTURAL PRESERVATION.
OVER THE LAST 25 YEARS, WE HAVE
BOUGHT BACK NUMEROUS BASKETS AND
ARTIFACTS, AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON BUILDING A CULTURAL
CENTER TO SHOWCASE OUR
COLLECTION, A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
SHARE OUR HISTORY AND TELL OUR
STORY. THE CENTER WILL ALSO
HOUSE A DEDICATED SPACE TO
PRESERVE OUR LANGUAGE,
CEREMONIES, SONGS, AND NATIVE
FOOD TRADITIONS THROUGH GAMING
REVENUE. WE SUPPORT THE
OPERATION OF OUR TRIBAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH SERVES TO
PROTECT OUR TRIBAL CITIZENS,
EMPLOYEES AND PATRONS. THE NEW
COMPACT WILL ALLOW OUR TRIBE TO
CONTINUE IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT, FIRE
PROTECTION AGENCIES AND OTHERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. THE REVENUE
GENERATED THROUGH GAMING HAS
ALLOWED US TO BUY BACK AND
RECLAIM OUR ORIGINAL LANDS AND
INCREASE OUR LAND BASE,
INCLUDING OUR TRIBAL CEMETERY.
MY AUNT, OUR LATE CHAIRWOMAN,
MISS BEVERLY J. HUNTER, WHO NOW
RESTS THERE, WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
FIGHTING TO BRING OUR TRIBE
CEMETERY. THE RESTING PLACE OF
OUR ANCESTORS, BACK UNDER OUR
POSSESSION. SHE BEGAN THESE
COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS WITH US,
AND I KNOW SHE, ALONG WITH ALL
OF OUR OTHER ANCESTORS, ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY. IN CLOSING, I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE TABLE MOUNTAIN
RANCHERIA GAMING COMPACT, AND
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS
TEAM FOR THEIR COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS IN REACHING AGREEMENT
WITH OUR TRIBE ON A NEW CLASS
THREE GAMING COMPACT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A FUTURE OF CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AND MUTUAL
SUCCESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIRWOMAN, ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS? CHAIRWOMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM HERE WANTING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS COMPACT. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, PAULA TREE ON
BEHALF OF TEJON AND COLUSA
TRIBES, ONE WHO HAS SECRETARIAL
PROCEDURES, WERE ALL IN FAVOR OF
THIS ON BEHALF OF PECHANGA, A
LONG TIME FRIEND OF TABLE
MOUNTAIN. WE ARE THRILLED WITH
THEIR SUCCESS, CHAIRMAN DAVID
QUINTANA ON BEHALF OF THE
CAHUILLA BAND OF INDIANS, THE
VIEJAS BAND OF KUMEYAAY INDIANS,
AND THE POMO OF UPPER LAKE, WE
SUPPORT TABLE MOUNTAIN'S
COMPACT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE
SEEING NONE? THAT CONCLUDES OUR
INFO HEARING ON THE TABLE
MOUNTAIN COMPACT. MR. CHAIR, CAN
I. MR. CHAIR, OVER HERE ON MY
LEFT. YES. I JUST WANT TO SAY
JUST SENATOR JONES, PLEASE.
THERE WAS SOME, YOU KNOW,
KERFUFFLE UP HERE. I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE CHAIRWOMAN AND
HER TEAM FOR DOING A GREAT JOB
OF BEING VERY GRACIOUS IN ALL OF
THIS AND HAVING TO PUT UP WITH
IT. YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB.
YOU'VE ALL. I'M PROUD OF YOU. SO
THANK YOU. AND THANKS FOR COMING
FORWARD. YES I THINK IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE SENATOR WHO
REPRESENTS THIS GREAT TRIBE TO
BE ABLE TO SAY A FEW WORDS. I
THANK THE CHAIR FOR INVITING ME
TO SIT ON THE DAIS THIS MORNING,
AS YOU HEARD, THE CHAIRWOMAN WAS
ELOQUENT, GRACIOUS, BUT FIRM IN
HER BELIEF TO REPRESENT HER
PEOPLE. AND I ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS THAT MADE
THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE DELAYS IN
COMPACTS TRULY ARE A SOVEREIGN
NATION, I, AS THE SENATE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT AREA, AND
I THINK ANY SENATOR WHO
REPRESENTED HEIGHTS DESIRES YOU
TO BE GOOD NEIGHBORS WITH YOUR
NEIGHBORING GOVERNMENT. AND ALL
OF YOU ARE SPECIFICALLY IN MY
AREA. I DON'T I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH OTHER AREAS. I'VE HEARD A
LOT OF PEOPLE COME INTO ME AND
SAY, WE HAVE TO DO THESE THINGS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TRIBES THAT
DON'T DO THIS. I'VE NEVER HEARD
OF ONE TRIBE NOT BEING A GOOD
NEIGHBOR TO THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, AND IT'S MY HONOR TO
REPRESENT THE TABLE MOUNTAIN
TRIBE, THE TULE RIVER TRIBE. BUT
ALSO, HAVING THIS CHAIRWOMAN.
AND OUT OF THE NINE MEMBER
COUNCIL, I BELIEVE THERE ARE SIX
WOMEN THAT ARE ON THIS COUNCIL.
AND AM I CORRECT OR NOT? OKAY.
SO IT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE THAT
WOMEN ARE TAKING A ROLE AND
BUYING BACK ANCESTRAL LANDS,
SPECIFICALLY THE CEMETERY, AND
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS GOOD
MEDICAL CARE. HIGHEST WAGES ARE
PAID IN THE 70 PERCENTILE,
ALMOST 80 PERCENTILE, $50,000 IN
LIFE INSURANCE, MEDICAL
BENEFITS, ALL THE THINGS THAT
YOU OFFER THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
FOR YOU, WHETHER THEY'RE A
TRIBAL PART OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY OR THE NOT BEING A
PART OF THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY,
YOU TAKE CARE OF THEM. AND IT'S
MY HONOR TO REPRESENT YOU. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THE MEMBER
COMMENTS. I THINK FOR THE AMOUNT
OF WORK AND TIME THAT'S GONE
INTO IT, THAT WAS VERY
APPROPRIATE, I DO WANT TO THANK
MR. LEE FOR THE GREAT JOB. THIS
IS OUR LAST COMPACT HEARING, I
BELIEVE, OF THE YEAR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOU'VE BEEN YOU'VE
DONE A GREAT JOB, BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU. CHAIRWOMAN
HEREDIA CORDOVA AND YOUR
MEMBERS, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS ADJOURNED.